le budget 2023 est un budget décevant et
inquiétant décevant parce qu'il
maintient un déficit en 2023 de 5% de
PIB de 158 milliards d'euros décevant
parce que c'est encore des augmentations
de dépenses 62 milliards d'euros de
dépenses en plus en 2023
décevant parce que un tiers des dépenses
de l'État sont payées par la dette par
l'emprunt inquiétant parce que le niveau
de la dette va atteindre 3000 milliards
d'euros dans quelques mois inquiétant
également parce que la charge de la
dette est interdit d'emprunt augmente de
quasiment 18 milliards d'euros pour
atteindre presque 60 milliards d'euros
en 2023 la France va recourir à 270
milliards d'emprunt pour financer le
déficit également pour rembourser les
emprunts qui arrivent à échéance
responsable et constructif les députés
les républicains ont fait des
propositions une première proposition de
diminution des dépenses par un plan de
sobriété bureaucratique pour simplifier
des bureaucratiser
constructif en faisant des propositions
pour soutenir le pouvoir d'achat au
travers des crédits d'impôts rénovation
thermique des crédits d'impôts soutien à
l'accession à la propriété et des
mesures pour soutenir les entreprises le
gouvernement n'a pas du tout retenu nos
propositions majeures et essentielles le
gouvernement n'est pas dans un
dispositif de redressement des finances
publiques c'est la raison pour laquelle
les députés les républicains ne peuvent
voter le budget 2023